I can identify as a black lesbian
belittling black people racist there he
goes again homophobic look at that
Gammon there's a Tick-Tock clip went
very viral it's had five million views
and it's me on International women's day
saying to a woman who had was in an
argument about
gender
I said so I can identify as a black
lesbian can I
and she said well that's ridiculous well
no it's not is it it's the logical
extension of what you've just said about
gender should be Limitless now in the
whole context of the whole conversation
everyone could see what I'm getting at
if all you've seen is a tick tock clip
of me saying I'm Piers Morgan and I'm a
black man there he goes again a
right-wing lunatic look at that Gammon
you know belittling black people racist
belittling
um gay people homophobic of course
there's none of those things I'm simply
saying if you have Limitless gender if
you can basically put your hand up and
say you could be whatever you want if
you just identify as it that's what
happens and if people don't believe me
look at the Scottish rapist who
literally took it to the worst possible
degree
and got away with it
um so that's that's I think they don't
like me calling them out on the logic of
their arguments because a lot of it is
illogical now Bill Maher in America is
one of my favorite commentators
in the world but he's on the left he's a
he's a probably like me politically
probably a liberal guy really at heart
and he finds him completely insufferable
the white Brigade insufferable and and
of course he's not electable this kind
of mentality most people aren't like it
who get on Kensington High Street and
you talk to 100 people and you put five
worked position to me I think you're
nuts
should be putting some Asylum but do not
worry peers that we talk and we focus on
gender and workers and look there's
something that we need to talk about but
you're a journalist you realize that
this country is in a dire dire situation
financially economically societally and
it just distracts from that and we don't
talk about it that's why you're wrong
I'll tell you why because it's not a
small thing
actually the way that we tackle Big
Stuff of the kind you're talking about
it comes down to leadership how can you
be a leader if you can't even say what a
woman is
who's going to follow you who's going to
take your lead what kind of person are
you now sakir Starman is very impressive
in many ways I like him personally but
he just refuses to say what a woman is
Rishi soon after his credit when I
interviewed him immediately said it's an
adult human female
great it's not difficult it's not a
trick question that's the answer
biological sex isn't just an irrefutable
fact so when a politician can't answer
that and answered your question he might
be leading the country in two years time
Kirsten a man who won't say what a woman
is because he's too scared does that
come for you doesn't comfort me so I
don't think these are small things I
think the battle for
freedom of speech we saw it with Gary
lineker again recently the battle for
someone's right to have an opinion the
battle to save what I call old-fashioned
debate the battle against this woke
fascist mentality that you will agree
with us or you will be destroyed take
care rally it must be destroyed at all
costs the order of political correctness
um all that has got to be fought and won
otherwise the rest of it can't get fixed
you're going to end up with leaders who
are incapable of leading because they
can't even answer basic questions
because they're too scared so that would
be my answer that it's not they're all
interlinked it's all about leadership
it's all about Freedom it's all about
understanding that what the Cornerstone
of democracy is is freedom and the
moment you infringe on that right to
freedom for the British public the
American public for any so-called
democracy that way hell lies is that
where you're heading into fascist